N'est-ce pas ?
La peur remplace l'inconnu par l'horreur.
La peur appelle la peur.
Quand vous vous confrontez au besoin
de prendre du recul et d'avoir un esprit critique,
la peur se niche au fond de votre esprit,
réduisant et déformant votre vue, freinant votre capacité à penser
de façon critique en créant un flux d'émotions perturbatrices.
Quand vous avez l'opportunité de faire quelque chose,
la peur vous paralyse,
vous incitant à la regarder passivement se réaliser.
Quand le diagnostic de ma maladie est tombé,
je savais que devenir aveugle allait gâcher ma vie.
Devenir aveugle, c'était la mort de mon indépendance.
C'était la fin de la réussite.
Devenir aveugle signifiait vivre une vie quelconque,
courte et triste,
et sûrement solitaire.
Je le savais.
Cela venait directement de mes peurs mais j'y croyais.
C'était faux, mais c'était ma réalité,
tout comme le poisson de Dorothée qui nage à l'envers.
Si je ne m'étais pas confronté à la réalité de ma peur,
je l'aurais vécue.
J'en suis certain.
Donc, comment vivre avec les yeux grands ouverts ?
C'est une discipline qui s'apprend.
Elle peut être enseignée. Elle peut être pratiquée.
Je vais vous faire un court résumé.
Soyez attentif
à chaque moment, chaque pensée, chaque détail.
Sachez voir au delà de vos peurs.
Reconnaissez vos fausses conjectures.
Exploitez votre force intérieure.
Faites taire votre critique interne.
Réajustez vos idées sur la chance et le succès.
Acceptez vos forces et faiblesses et comprenez la différence.
Ouvrez vos cœurs à vos innombrables chances.
Vos peurs, vos critiques,
vos héros, vos méchants...
sont vos excuses,
vos prétextes, vos justifications, qui vous poussent à abandonner.
Ce sont des mensonges perçus comme une réalité.
Choisissez de voir au travers. Choisissez de les abandonner.
Vous êtes le créateur de votre réalité.
C'est là que vous pourrez vous émanciper.
J'ai choisi de sortir du tunnel de la peur pour sauter dans l'inconnu
et j'ai choisi d'y construire une vie merveilleuse.
Loin d'être seul,
je partage ma vie avec
ma magnifique femme, Dorothée,
et nos triplés, les « Tripskys »,
et la petite dernière de la famille, l'adorable Clémentine.
De quoi avez-vous peur ?
Vous mentez-vous à vous-même ?
Comment magnifiez-vous votre vérité et écrivez vos propres fictions ?
À quoi ressemble votre réalité ?
Dans votre carrière, votre vie privée, dans vos relations,
dans votre cœur et votre âme,
vos poissons rouges vous nuisent.
Ils causent un grand nombre d'opportunités manqués et de potentiel gaspillé,
ils engendrent l'insécurité et la méfiance
là où vous cherchez l'accomplissement.
Je vous somme de les examiner.
Helen Keller a dit :
« L’unique chose qui puisse être pire que d’être aveugle
est d’avoir la vue, mais pas de vision. »
Pour moi, devenir aveugle a été une véritable bénédiction
parce qu'être aveugle m'a donné la vision.
J'espère que vous pourrez voir ce que je vois.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Isaac, juste une question avant que vous partiez.
C'est une audience d'entrepreneurs, d'innovateurs.
Vous êtes PDG d'une entreprise en Floride,
et beaucoup se demandent sûrement :
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être un PDG aveugle ?
Quels types de défis spécifiques rencontrez-vous ?
Isaac Lidsky : Eh bien, le plus gros défi est devenu une chance.
Je ne vois pas la réaction directe des gens.
(Rires)
BG : Alors, c'est quoi ce bruit ? IL : Ouais.
Par exemple, pendant les réunions avec mon équipe de direction,
je ne vois ni les expressions du visage, ni les gestes.
J'ai appris à demander une communication orale.
Je force les gens à me dire ce qu'ils pensent.
À cet égard,
c'est devenu, comme je l'ai dit, une chance pour moi et mon entreprise.
Car la communication en est devenue excellente.
Nous évitons ainsi toute ambigüité,
et surtout mon équipe sait que son avis compte vraiment.
BG : Isaac, merci d'être venu. IL : Merci, Bruno.
(Applaudissements)